THE JONATHAN TOEWS  HALL TO
PLAY DEFENSE ON
BLOCKER SAVED AND
CHARLIE COYLE
MATTER, THEY WAVED IT
OFF ANYWAY.
BUT HE DOESN'T PLAY
THE PUCK FIFI ALEX
DEBRINCAT FLIPS OVER
TO PATRICK AND, TWO
ON ONE , AND ALEX IN
TROUBLE IF YOU'RE
GOING TO PITCH THERE,E,
LANKINEN.NHL GOAL.
JACK A SEANIT WITH
A STICK.
ALMOST MAKES IT LOOK
LIKE HE'S GO
THE BRUINS MUSCULAR
IN THE POWERPLAY EN TEA
AGAIN, YOWHAT'S AHEAD F
PASTERNAK.
THREAD THE GREAT
WAY TO TRANSFER THE
PUCK FROM ONE SIDE OF S
SLIPS IT TO DYLAN THE R
CHICAGO LOOKS LIKE
THE GOING TO GET A
LITTLE SOMETHIN CHARGES
THE ATTACKING ZONE
AND LICHEN AND MAKESTEE
THE NET.
THAT'S PATRICK KANE
BACK THERE.
TO GET AWAYAY
THE WALL.
CARR
SLIPS IT TO SPACE.
McAVOY LOOKING KIRBY DA
RUSH LATE IN THE 3rd.
SWAYMAN, VERY PASTERNAK
POUNCES.
WHAT A REVERSAL OF
GOOD BALANCE.
THEY ROTATE BACK TO
THE FRONT OF THE NET.
IT GETS MY BERGERON.
IT GET